[Music]
hello there reject nation happy Friday
or happy what everyday you're watching
this on time and space that's your boy
John Humphrey coming at you with another
TV show reaction having a little bit
bummer e of a day I lost my notebook so
I figured you know what I can use a
distraction so recently I started a new
show all the kids are hopped up about
these days the old Riverdale based on
the classic Archie comics now full
disclosure I've seen the pilot episode
already and I dug it for the most part
you know it managed to hook me I'm
excited to see the second episode here
and before we get into it I'm just gonna
play my startups reaction so you guys
can get a brief sense for how I'm
feeling about the series so far so
yesterday we checked out the first
episode of Riverdale and I gotta say by
the end of it I was really enjoying it I
mean it took me a little time to jump
into it it is you know kind of a soap
opera for sure but to see the artsy
characters updated in such a you know
sleek but also tongue-in-cheek kind of
way I love the murder mystery angle I
love the way it's shot and I thought the
cast really shone there's some good
writing in there so overall I thought it
was you know a solid pilot and I
definitely want to watch more excited so
yeah those are my thoughts you know
pulled me in I'm enjoying the sort of
teen intrigue melodrama angle and I love
the aesthetics I love the way that it
looks and I think the cast is all really
charming so yeah I'm hooked so far so
episode 2 here is called Touch of Evil
and I'm very excited to see where this
goes according to Jughead and a rest
will be made unless they're gonna skip
right past that it is something more
intriguing but anyhow as usual we can
only show about 10 minutes of the actual
reaction in this episode but if you want
to see the full thing come join us on
patreon comm slash the real rejects got
a whole bunch of cool exclusive content
over there music videos and exclusive
reactions we got a Q&A segment it's a
lot of fun we've got a great community
over there so come on down let's get to
it
around on July 4th we'd come to school
Monday morning and there Jason would be
or simply an image ship a corpse with a
bullet hole in its forehead and terrible
secrets that could only be revealed but
a cold steel blade of coroner's autopsy
scalpel telltale beating of a guilty
heart I'm sorry
he's just art she's so sexy Eddie bad
deed that's her name it's gonna be hard
for them living next to rich dude he's
so sexy
we'll stop all of those 80cents scores
man you could be expelled
who's a bad situation man Archie no more
midnight runs until the police catch
whoever wasn't shot that poor kid god
this town this is the sociopathic sign
of the wealthiest family in town
murdered that's a national obsession
waiting to happen
he's barely in his grave can you warm up
the car huh I'll be right down
Oh are we 100% sure that aren't you
straight because no straight man has
that body Jason it was more traumatizing
having to explain to my dad what I was
doing with moose at the river yet
another perk of being the sheriff's son
oh my god those are gorgeous please give
me one more chance
fighting full French really awesome I'll
take it what's going on Betty do you you
okay it's summer we were supposed to go
on a road trip over July 4th weekend
which you bailed on at the last minute
oh you want to tell me pal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are several morbid details you
should
why are you - what did moose one oh my
god I don't even think he knows I mean I
am devastatingly handsome in that
classic pre-accident Montgomery Clift
kind of way and sexuality is fluid but
can someone named moose actually be that
fluid okay
well of course you would you're a big
city girl with loose morals
[Music]
Oh
you okay that's what the nice girl
always says but no I'm not I want to be
baby wait
oh no not path
[Music]
insured Oh guys or windows here oh no
actually I knew Cheryl I have a gift
certificate for hers-and-hers mani-pedis
influence on Oh Betty
damn cold as hell
[Music]
because he dumped cow someone shot my
brother and I think it was your crazy
tweaked-out sister oh man she's great at
being hateable give her that
oh whoa whoa
Betty it's badass
yeah
we heard a gunshot B gunshot dude you
have to tell somebody and if you tell
anyone about this
what are you gonna do he was just
leaving
No
good answer
when you shot Jason you didn't do so for
the body like after it's called
necrophilia Reggie can you spell it
oh man
[Music]
change the elephant
[Music]
good dad right there thank you
Friday night Waits
[Music]
you you might need me
we're telling whether it be we're not
gonna hug in front of this whole town
and if we both just do that for a thing
where we not like douches and mutually
suppress our emotions over many burgers
many days yay Archie
[Music]
oh ho oh I love a little moment like
that I wonder if it just actually rained
and they just had to use their music
sound
[Music]
yeah
right I ask Oh
Oh
something weird about the two of that
man oh man oh no interesting
[Music]
all right not a bad episode pretty
pretty gripping episode I gotta say out
autoplay I love how confrontational this
show is with everything because right
off the bat I'm so surprised at how
quickly this is all moving and I do
appreciate a show that'll do that that
will set things up and confront them
right away instead of letting them sort
of percolate for a whole season and then
finally confronting them at the end and
a lot of people complain out of the
Walking Dead for ruminating too much I
just love the sort of tone they've taken
with this show cuz it is kind of like a
soap opera for sure but I love the
murder mystery aspect and the sort of
town intrigue and the fact that you're
peering in on so many different dynamics
between all these characters you see
everybody often different pairs and how
they all feel and interact with each
other and I like that they're taking
time to make you know strong choices
with their character moments and those
are backed up by the actors cuz there
are a lot of moments in this episode I
thought really affecting that really
sold the stakes not only of the murder
mystery stuff the intrigue but also just
the stakes of coming of age and dealing
with high school and dealing with those
kinds of issues you know like stuff you
would have faced in high school I really
enjoy the nuances that they're bringing
to the table and then some of the more
pulpy elements they're bringing to the
table it's always beautifully shot and
again the cast I'm really enjoying -
everybody has had moments that have
really grabbed to me in these first two
episodes and I'm just I'm so happy to
see Archie and Jughead on the mend I was
looking forward to that well the whole
thing between Archie and the music
teacher I thought that was handled
really well and I do like again that
there is a lot of nuance to the
performance cuz that scene they share in
the music room where they have that
really up-close conversation I like that
they allow you to revel in that moment
for a minute so you're sitting there and
you're going she's trying to seduce him
isn't she well maybe there's a
connection here I don't know you get
caught up in the emotions of those
moments and I feel like they're pretty
good at giving these characters some
psychology so even when they're not
telling you what their philosophy is or
what they're doing they're showing it
through the performances and through
some of the writing in more subtle ways
that's something about the show that's
been impressing me that I wasn't
necessarily expecting and even the adult
cast
like all those characters - I mean the
relationship between Archie Anna's dad I
think is great
Betty's mom something else Veronica's
mom seems pretty interesting so far uh
Shh Sheryl blossom man I keep wanting to
say bloom because Jason blossom makes me
think of jason blum it's Cheryl blossom
oh my goodness that character I also I
love the structure of these episodes
were like each one hints that like
here's a big thing that happens right at
the end and we're gonna confront this
pretty much at the beginning of the next
episode so yeah this whole thing with
Cheryl I mean from the beginning it's
been pretty clear that she's probably
not super trustworthy but even so I was
still wondering how that was gonna play
out I didn't know if that was gonna be a
mislead of some kind and there could
still I'm sure there's still a lot of
surprises coming out of that but oh man
that though she is such a witch most the
time she's just got that steely sort of
conniving energy never trusted that
character but Madeleine pageant me know
like her performance is terrific because
she's just so slimy and hateable and
she's got that rhythm down to his
science
oh he's appreciating really well playing
antagonist and she really brings a lot
to that and the whole relationship
between Betty and Veronica - like there
was a whole lot to this episode like I
said I feel like that's a benefit of the
way that they're choosing the handle all
this is like they're confronting a lot
each episode and so that keeps things
moving and keeps things interesting and
the whole thing between Betty and
Veronica from the last episode you know
carrying over and did this one the way
that they've been working on these
friendship dynamics I thought was really
affecting and really resonant you know
it felt kind of authentic even though
you know it is a show it is pulpy and
stylized I think the emotional beats of
that and figuring out the triangle with
Betty Veronica and Archie after the
incident in the first episode I thought
they handled that in a really nice way
over the course of the whole episode and
they're balancing each part of this well
I think and I love Kevin so much he and
moose I'm curious to see if that
develops into anything beyond this but
overall man I really enjoyed this
episode I mean it made me laugh I almost
teared up a couple times and there's
plenty of mystery that's left me
scratching my head and really wanting to
see the next episode I can really see I
don't binge much but this is definitely
a vegetable show I feel like because I
already want to start the next one
so yeah I hope you guys enjoyed this and
I'll be back at some point soon with the
episode 3 until then you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is out you can
follow us on the Stardust app where we
post 30-second reactions and reviews to
any TV show movie or trailer come join
us over there if you haven't already and
as always come and join us on our
patreon will have the full-length
version of this reaction on there as
well and until next time folks Cheers